this movie was slow and timid no it's uh
it's fast and furious seven some of the
last movie Luke Evans played Owen Shaw
Owen Shaw was taken down by the family
and now his big brother Deckard Shaw or
for this a dickard Shaw played by Jason
Statham is now out for revenge against
the Furious family early on you can feel
that this film is very different from
its last installment
I mean Furious 6 was just like
ridiculous adventurous film like this
film was great because he kept all of
that yet it portrayed a rather serious
more dramatic tone which actually like
amped up the intensity I really got to
give credit to James Bond for taking on
this franchise he's you guys don't know
who he is he directed films like saw
insidious the conjuring so this dude
primarily has a horror movie background
which at first sounded like an odd
choice for like the next Fast and
Furious film but after watching it
there's no one else I would have had
rather do this movie think about it this
guy has worked for many years on
suspense and he brought that level of
suspense to this movie this film has a
water ridiculous like unbelievable
moments even in those times who was
still kind of intense when that scene in
the trailer and Paul Walker's running up
the bus that that's a scary [ __ ] yeah
but like beyond the suspense he also
knew when to make it funny you went to
make it heartfelt he wants a shooter
like a music video I swear like the
first 10 minutes you're just looking at
women's asses I didn't like that baby I
didn't like Leah knows all those asses
at the beginning of the movie liar you
had the great thing about bringing him
on board is that I think he understands
characters better too I think he can
direct actors better as well so this
film certainly had character it
certainly had emotion and unlike earlier
installments prior to Fast Five the
drama actually
aids in the storytelling writing
one-on-one will teach you that character
is the most important ingredient to any
screenplay
it's really knew how to capture Jason
Statham
he establishes Deckard Shaw really well
you can immediately see how intense this
guy is and the film like kind of starts
off from his perspective so you sort of
understand what this do so angry about
I mean his brother is crippled this
penis probably doesn't work anymore
if my brother's ps2 don't work anymore I
would be concerned I don't know I would
go after the people that did that to him
because of them didn't mean it just
wants to avenge a family member and out
of all the Fast & Furious films this
villain was set up the best Jason
Statham he's an intimidating
[ __ ] but some others too
sometimes
it was cool to see Jason Statham who was
usually a protagonist now in an
antagonist role and is quite believable
in it as well
yes oh and that could that was released
online that everyone was asking me to
watch i totally avoided it because i
wanted to just see it in the movie when
i watch the movie but that fight scene
with Jason Statham and dwayne johnson
holy [ __ ] those two dudes were like but
[ __ ] each other or something man if
we're going to add it rough that's cool
because we know the rock can fight and
we know Jason Statham can fight but we
also know they have two very different
styles so when you see that style come
together on brutality
it's [ __ ] entertaining to watch and
doing Johnson isn't in this movie a
whole lot but I love him as Hobbs Hobbs
takes himself so serious that he's kind
of a joke but at the same time you
wouldn't [ __ ] with him because I mean
look at him at the beginning of this
movie Vin Diesel is still trying to get
Michelle Rodriguez to remember he's like
stop having amnesia [ __ ] but I wanna
talk about Michelle Rodriguez really
fast I think she deserves a lot more
credit for her work in these last two
films she really captures like this
lonely lost soul with like a mysterious
anger
she's dirty and nasty but she's my kind
of attractive for some reason camera I'm
quite pinpoint it you know she's kind of
like a dude like hottie but she's
someone we can't remember her past and
all Ben diesel can see is the last 15
years they had together
she is someone who needs to find herself
and it came across slightly cheesy but
yet even though it was cheesy I was like
you know what I'm feeling the emotion
here I'm feeling the emotion even in
cheesy moments the emotion is felt and
we get to see Michelle Rodriguez at one
point in a more sexy classy red outfit
and she fights that a fighter Ronda
Rousey Rousey Ronda Rousey I know baby
that was a cool fight nothing like
watching two hot [ __ ] go at it ain't
that right baby Paul Walker is now a dad
who misses the bullets I must say I
found myself occasionally asking myself
what are they gonna do with Brian
O'Connor are they gonna fully wrap him
up will this be a worthy payoff or
worthy send-off I'm not just saying this
this was the best Brian O'Connor we have
gotten from The Fast and Furious
franchise I thought he was totally
entertaining to watch he's everything we
already like about Paul Walker but even
more he's more natural he's more
confident he was a father in real life
so it's nice to see like his fatherly
side and like every website has been
mentioning this but there's a ending
tribute at the ends of Paul Walker
everyone's saying like it's a good
send-off for Paul Walker and yeah yeah
it was great it was very moving and like
a lot of people in the theater I was
crying my girlfriend wasn't crying
though she punched me in the face
Vin Diesel as Dominic Toretto is the
master at being cool about cars he says
everyone with confidence even when he's
panicking he still looks kind of
confident you know he leads this makeup
franchise and there's no one else better
to lead this particular franchise like
the rock occasionally says cheesy lines
that sound super [ __ ] cheesy Vin
Diesel can take a cheesy line and make
it sound so cool Tyrese Gibson and Luda
kiss kiss Tyrese Gibson and Ludacris are
black
ah they're back I love these guys Tyrese
is a jokester Ludacris is tech-savvy and
I really like seeing Ludacris in this
role because he is a well-known rapper
but he doesn't portray
rappers type of image and all in these
films he's believable as kind of the
nerdy one of these guys but a cool nerd
Tyrese I love how he's so confident so
charismatic and he's not afraid to make
an ass out of himself like one thing I
would say is that this film could have
used just a tad bit more humor but the
humor really stays alive between Tyrese
Gibson and Ludacris
last performance I got to mention Kurt
Russell as mr. nobody from the trailer I
thought he would literally just be that
someone who's like oh it's Kurt Russell
but he's just playing a normal dude no
this guy is a character you have to cast
an actor like Kurt Russell to play this
character he's fun to watch it was a
delightful surprise at times you don't
know if you should trust him or not but
I would still love to see this character
continue in the franchise now of course
how can you do a fast and furious review
without mentioning the action sequences
the action sequences are beyond awesome
there's a lot of there's a lot of a quad
a lot of action and there's about four
majorly awesome scenes that come to mind
you've seen a lot of the footage of the
trailer the chase through the canyons
was great the car falling out of the
airplane was awesome Jason Statham in
the rock fighting and it is one long
epic finale like it is a long epic
finale orgasm oh no the finale still
intense it's still creative there's a
lot of wonderful payoffs and it does
each character justice Oh anyway okay
I'm actually Tony Jaa's in this he's the
unbox i warrior dude
I completely forgot he was even gonna be
in this but I'm glad he makes an
appearance because you really got to
show off his unique set of skills in a
big American franchise and I hope this
gets him more attention so yes this film
is everything you loved about Fast Five
and Furious 6 and fast and furious Tokyo
Drift
the best one of them all quote me on
that take me seriously but this one has
even more substance let me get straight
to the point here all in all I gotta say
Furious 7 got it fast and
seriously right alright guys thanks for
checking out my review for Furious 7 you
can go ahead and leave your thoughts on
Furious 7 in the comment box below
because I'm an interactive youtuber you
can follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
cuz I'm an interactive youtuber last but
not least if you want to get updated
every time one of my videos or reviews
this out
go buddy click on this button I might
dig this subscribe cuz I'm an
interactive youtuber that's right the
dick let me tell you something about
this little racecar every time his motor
begins to rev as well as the engine and
he greets his beautiful lady he treats
her to something that is pounding fast
and furiously seven times in a row and
when he's done she's not she always asks
for one last ride